news and opinions expressed on this
program are those of the guests
appearing on the program and do not
necessarily reflect the views and
opinions of 8 news now or next our media
group
so yes there is a fear that you know
at any point someone could be outside my
door
tonight on politics now nevada lawmakers
take cover as the president's supporters
storm the capitol building they describe
the ordeal and what they believe should
happen now
plus and we already made
some tough decisions and cut our state
budget by 30 i don't believe 12 percent
productions across the board are the
answer
the legislative session is just weeks
away leaders from both parties tell us
their priorities in carson city
from 8 news now this is politics now
it is in writing but unfortunately no
united states senator
has joined in this effort
[Applause]
in that case the objection cannot be
entertained
and with that nevada's electoral votes
for president-elect joe biden
are finally counted we thank you for
joining us here on politics now i'm john
langler
after a wild and troubling week in
washington d.c
the normally mundane electoral vote
counting process took an ugly turn on
wednesday
inside the capitol halls a group of
republicans attempted to contest the
results
outside the walls the president's
supporters attacked the building and
eventually got inside
the subsequent riot left one capitol
hill police officer
and at least four other people dead
raquel martin reports
and the people's work continue
after chaos erupted when the president's
supporters forced their way into the
halls of congress
lawmakers returned to the capitol to
certify the electoral college results
criminal behavior will never
dominate the united states congress we
will not be diverted from our duty the
uprising prompted some republicans like
outgoing georgia senator kelly leflers
to reverse course
and i cannot now in good conscience
object to the certification
count me out enough is enough still more
than 100 house lawmakers
and six republican senators voted to
reject the electoral college votes in
some states
so this is the appropriate place for
these concerns to be raised missouri
senator josh hawley who led
objections in the senate insists
unfounded allegations of fraud
should be investigated democrats slammed
the idea
they're asking us to ignore court
rulings ignore republican election
officials and even
worse ignore the will of the people and
blame president trump for stoking the
violence this mob was invited to come to
washington
on this day by this president the nose
have it
ultimately objections to results in
pennsylvania and arizona
were opposed shall be deemed a
sufficient declaration
of the person's elected president
congress certified joe biden's victory
just after 3 a.m in washington raquel
martin
nevada's congressional delegation was
among those left in hiding as the mob of
president trump's supporters
descended on the capitol building in
washington the i-team's david charns
spoke with several of the lawmakers
about their experience
david hello hey there john well
congresswoman susie lee was in her
office when she received a text message
saying to stay away from windows and see
cover you can see here why here's what
she told me about
watching the complex get stormed we
talked to her on the phone as she
remained in lockdown it was
very scary because not only were you
seeing our capitol police being
overwhelmed
uh on tv across the street but then
knowing that there were
other uh you know instances that were
requiring some attention and you know
not knowing uh if someone could possibly
have breached
the building that i was in well police
did eventually get a handle on those
riders they use
tear gas grenades clearing those armed
protesters from the area
congresswoman dina titus tweeting this
as she sat in lockdown
today lawless domestic terrorists
encouraged by the president of the
united states
attempted to destroy our democracy and
prevent the peaceful transfer of power
nevada senator catherine cortez masto
describing her
ideal as well so they asked everybody to
stay in their seats
they secured all the doors said you're
going to be safe here they put a
capitol police on all the doors and then
we could hear the loud commotion we
could hear
the voices and the noises outside
and these are some of the photos she
took hours after being moved to a secure
location pretty scary
stuff there at the capitol on wednesday
john
yeah dramatic scenes uh from the
nation's capital david now ever since
wednesday there's been talk mostly by
democrats but by some republicans about
either
the 25th amendment but also possibly
trying to impeach president trump before
his term
ends where does nevada's delegation
stand on that well keep in mind this
would be a very short timeline since the
president has just two weeks left in
office
it would start of course in the house
just like the previous impeachment
three nevada democrats in the house all
three of them congresswoman titus
lee congressman stephen horsford as well
say they would vote for this
senator cortez masto telling me that she
wants to see what the house does first
before making a decision
and senator jackie rosen has also not
yet called for
impeachment and david any response from
nevada's only republican on capitol hill
in washington congressman mark yamaday
no john he has not yet weighed in on
this
well we'll keep asking and we'll wait
for an answer david thank you very much
for the reaction from washington from
the congressional delegation after a
very wild wednesday
so there have been a lot of conspiracy
theories circulating about who was
actually
involved in the riot on capitol hill
those conspiracy theories well our
washington dc correspondent alexander
limon has more on that she was
at the capitol at the time of the riot
alex you were up on capitol hill when
this all took place
on wednesday uh so you saw it firsthand
what it was like
in the aftermath there have been some
conspiracy theories about
uh who really was involved in the the
riot up on capitol hill
what is known about who was taking part
in this destruction on capitol hill
yeah absolutely and conspiracy theory is
the right word for that these
online social media claims that
antifa or left-wing protesters were to
blame for these protests that is not the
case and there is plenty of evidence
video evidence of thousands of president
trump's
supporters attending his rally where he
spoke where he told them
to head to the capitol and then they did
that and a short time after that they
breached the capitol and again
four people died as a result and
after that happened in the evening
president trump released that video
message on social media and
even he didn't claim that they weren't
his supporters in fact he said things
like
we love you but please go home now so
even he
admitted and knows they were his
supporters
who caused this violence and these riots
in dc on wednesday so
these claims that it was antifa or
somebody else
are totally false in fact the mayor of
dc
said that the leader of the proud boys
for example was arrested here in
washington this week
so we know who did this it was
right-wing groups
like the proud boys and president trump
supporters there's no question about
that
yeah quite the scene on capitol hill
glad you're uh safe from it and uh we'll
certainly see how things play out alex
thank you very much for joining us
now we should point out after we spoke
with alexandra a fifth person
died from the ride that capitol hill
police officer
also we should point out that arrests
have started to be made by federal
investigators since then so
this is an ongoing situation the house
appropriations committee is also looking
into this they are starting to
investigate why capitol hill police were
simply not prepared
for what took place on wednesday now on
the same day as the
the riot and the electoral college vote
georgia's two senate seats both went
democratic
democrat rafael warnock beat incumbent
republican kelly leffler
and jon ossoff beat republican david
perdue another incumbent
both victories were by more than would
have triggered an automatic recount in
georgia as well
and the races have been conceded in
total democrats
picked up four senate seats in
washington from the november election
so that splits the senate 50-50
republicans and democrats however
vice president-elect kamala harris being
a democrat she
is the tie-breaking vote in the senate
so that gives democrats control of the
senate the house
and the white house when the
inauguration takes place
nevada senator catherine cortez masto
chairs the democratic senatorial
campaign committee
in a joint statement with current senate
minority leader chuck schumer she said
in part
rafael and john have earned the trust
and the support of voters across georgia
in a record-breaking election
and we look forward to fighting
alongside them for health jobs and
justice in the senate
coming up next on politics now eyes on
carson city
and i think our priorities are going to
continue to be
helping nevada come out of this pandemic
and this economic downturn
[Music]
assembly speaker jason fryerson tells us
about democrat priorities in the
legislative session plus
we need to be open in some shape or form
virtual or in person that's republican
assemblyman tom roberts
he tells us why he thinks the
legislative session should be held
safely
welcome back to politics now
nevada's 2021 legislative session starts
february 1st
so we're going to focus on the big
topics as going to be discussed at the
session
i spoke with the leaders of each party
and we're going to start with assembly
speaker jason fryerson
about his legislative priorities i
remember over the summer you
and and attorney general ford and others
were over at the grant sawyer building
discussing racial injustice police
reform during the black lives matter
protests
how much of that discussion will stretch
into the legislative session i know it
was discussed at the special session to
some extent but
what do you want to see discussed when
all the lawmakers are back up in carson
city
well i still think that we're going to
have some discussions about social
justice and about
uh community policing and just ideas on
how to
best uh you know protect the public i am
committed to making sure
that all of our stakeholders at the
table including the law enforcement
community
i think that we avoid unintended
consequences when we have everybody at
the table
but i do think that there are you know
are
still ways that we can better police our
community
better provide criminal justice uh more
efficiently and i think
you know there are some ways that we we
use money that might not be the most
efficient
or the wisest way to use money whether
it's how we treat traffic tickets
um how we look at the the cash bail
system
uh i i think you know continuing to look
at
crime and punishment and whether or not
we are being smart with our resources
and uh incarcerating the most dangerous
individuals but not wasting taxpayer
dollars
um housing people that don't pose uh
a har a risk of harm to the community so
those are conversations we'll continue
to have
but we'll certainly have them with uh
law enforcement at the table have you
had any conversations uh
leading up to this session with uh
sheriff lombardo for example
uh other law enforcement leaders across
the state
about union members about trying to make
put
this into action uh i have absolutely
had conversations i was just on the
phone with the sheriff a couple of days
ago
um uh and um
one one of his members of his
administration and i
have a a working relationship and
committed to reconnecting uh next week
to just talk about where we are and
where we can find common ground
uh i have asked them tell me you know
what is it that would help you better
um meet the community's needs meet your
agency's needs
i think that the conversation with uh
the police union has unfortunately
become far more political and partisan
than i think it warrants and so we're
gonna work on that uh i've committed
with them
uh to meeting with them weekly during
session and i'll follow through on that
to hear them out
and um and make sure that those
perspectives are reflected in the policy
discussions
this is going to be a difficult
legislative session
in in your experience in in public
service
just how challenging is the task
for you and all lawmakers to
to get the business done given the
limited resources
uh and also just given the circumstances
of the pandemic
it's going to be incredibly difficult i
don't know that i i am aware of any
session
that uh has presented the kind of
challenges that we're facing right now
we're facing challenges with respect to
the the tough budget decisions that
we're going to have to make
um but we're also facing i think
political challenges about
rhetoric and about how we're going to
govern um and how we're going to lead
i have always said that i believe
there's power both in the majority and
in the minority and [ __ ]
and you know crafting policy and i think
that we all are going to have to
uh put partisanship aside at times and
either advance policies that we think
are good for the state or mitigate
policies that we think
maybe aren't so good for the state and
if any um
part of the machine walks away and
doesn't participate in that i think
we're doing a disservice
to to to nevada so i am hopeful that uh
the four leaders of our four caucuses
can continue
to talk speaker fryerson also says he
thinks there will be fewer bills at the
legislative session simply because of
the precautions they're going to have to
take
during the pandemic republican
assemblyman tom roberts he is the
co-deputy minority floor leader
i spoke with him about republican
priorities at the legislative session
especially the budget and how the
session could be run during the pandemic
how are you going to work with democrats
to try and achieve your needs and
achieve the needs of your constituents
while also still
you know staying within the confines of
the budget during a special session
uh you know we cut the the budgets uh
pretty far back i think you're going to
see a continuation
of a lot of those cuts due you know due
to the revenue shortfall
from you know the governor's closures um
you know obviously the the the budget
you know it's got
really three big holes you know big
three big
items that we fund you know it's it's uh
education uh you know health care
uh you know and uh you know in public
safety issues
you know and actually delivering
government services
um you know to the state and so you know
those are those are your
those are your biggest biggest ones and
you know we're going to have to ensure
that we continue to provide
services to the citizens of nevada
but i think we also need to be cognizant
that the federal government
did put a lot of money into our state
under the first
relief act under covid i mean almost 19
billion dollars
have came to our state you know in our
bi-annual budget is eight
eight eight point something million i
don't believe twelve percent
productions across the board are the
answer uh you know so it'd be
interesting to see what the governor's
proposal
will be uh you know coming up and then
we'll work from there
obviously you were former assistant
sheriff and and we've talked
with current sheriff libardo about
issues of police reform in light of the
black lives matter protests
in my conversations with him he has
essentially said at that time anyway
he had not had a lot of conversations
with state lawmakers with
clark county committee there hasn't been
too much of an in-depth discussion of
what's going to happen
up in carson city at the legislative
session so
how much of that disgust reform do you
think will actually get discussed at the
legislative session
well you know i think we did some things
during a special session
uh that uh law enforcement approved
uh for the most part in the state uh i
know there's gonna be some
uh some bills that are gonna want to
push
reform further um you know
i i think folks like sheriff lombardo
and police leaders in our state are
willing to be at the table and talk
about reform issues
i think what a lot of people don't
realize is that
a lot of things that we do in nevada are
considered best practices in the
in the nation uh we can always make
improvements
and you know i think you know we're
always willing to be at the table to
talk about it
the mechanics of the legislative session
uh obviously during the interim period
there's
it's been mostly virtual all of it's
been virtual essentially do you
envision that continuing i i certainly
hope not i believe
you know i've participated in some uh
some phone calls with some
national organizations and and heard
from speakers
uh and in folks in other legislators
legislatures
around the country and and and other
bodies have found a way to have
um you know limited public access and
reduce public access you know we're not
gonna
i just under the current conditions i
just you know there's probably no way to
be 100
open but certainly we can figure out a
way to have limited capacity
allow people to to testify in hearings
to be able to ask questions we can't do
what we did during the special session
you know and have public comment for two
minutes
you can see the full interviews with
speaker fryerson and assemblyman roberts
at eightnewsnow.com just look for the
politics tab
coming up next here on politics now
concerns about fairness
as a governing trustee she's going to be
potentially in a position to make
decisions
that are adverse to ccva
what's ahead for the new clark county
school district board
welcome back to politics now the largest
local teachers union
is threatening an ethics complaint
against a new trustee
it claims lisa guzman is part of a rival
teachers union
the nevada state education association
the ccea
and the nsea they're involved in a
lawsuit
ccea staff say this creates a conflict
of interest
the nsea told us guzman resigned as
executive director of that union
december 1st
however they did not tell us that she
was only given the title of executive
assistant executive director instead
guzman was one of three new trustees of
sworn in this week organa looks at the
school board's busy agenda
a warm welcome as three new ccsd
trustees are sworn in monday night the
biggest priority for them and the rest
of the board
is if and when to reopen schools amid
the kovit 19 pandemic
i wish i could give our families a
straightforward answer trustee evelyn
garcia morales doesn't want to rush a
decision especially with new changes
being made to the hybrid learning
proposal
the model right now is currently being
reassessed by the superintendent and his
team
and so when i have the full picture i
will be able to make a better assessment
but trustee katie williams who has
gained a lot of attention for her
outspoken tweet supports in-person
learning
saying distance education has been a
burden for parents i think that those
parents just need a release they need a
break
and what i'm trying to do is get the
schools open for that reason
trustee lisa guzman says she wants to
see more data but the local teachers
union ccea
claims there's a conflict of interest
because of guzman's executive role with
the nevada state education association
as a governing trustee she's going to be
potentially in a position to make
decisions
that are adverse to ccea
ccea wants guzman to recuse herself from
certain votes guzman says she'll do that
if the nevada commission on ethics says
so i'm
working with the ccsd to
get some information from the ethics
advisory so that
we can clear the situation up
and that was oracle mana reporting in
what to watch
this week governor steve sisilak has his
state of the state address
this one though will be pre-recorded
it'll be published online january 19th
he'll outline the legislative priorities
moving forward